[Musique]
bienvenue dans cet entretien politique
avec jean michel fourgous bonjour
bonjour alors on va revenir un peu sur
votre sur votre parcours à travers un
portrait voilà qu'on a réalisé vous
pourrez interrompre quand vous voulez
pour donner des précisions pour corriger
si vous voulez des des choses qui vous
paraissent inexactes et puis on
terminera en parlant aussi un peu
d'actualité parce que c'est une
actualité importante entre la situation
sanitaire l'économie et les deux sont
indéniablement liés on va commencer si
vous voulez bien part parce ce portrait
qui s'appelle la politique autrement
[Musique]
maire d'elancourt depuis 1996 président
de saint quentin en yvelines est réélu
pour la deuxième fois dans cette
fonction il a aussi été député de la 11e
circonscription des yvelines
la première fois c'était en 1993 près de
trente ans de vie politique donc avec
pas mal de succès et quelques revers
mais qu'est ce qui fait courir
jean michel fourgous quelles sont les
raisons profondes de son engagement
politique et les convictions qui fonde
son action
c'est ce que nous allons tenter de
comprendre ensemble tout commence à la
fin des années 80 né à montreuil dans un
milieu modeste
jean michel fourgous a ratissé du das
saison il a abandonné ses études il est
rentré chez ibm au bas de l'échelle
comme comédie et après il a repris ses
études plus tard mais je pense que cette
période de sa vie a été déterminante
dans ses idées qu'il ya aujourd'hui de
se dire hé bé oui avec l'informatique à
l'époque on disait pas le numérique
l'informatique on peut acquérir des
compétences
au plus rapidement je termine seconde à
cette question d'études que vous abordez
il y avait des matières dans lequel vous
étiez doux et d'autres moins mais au
fond c'est que pas cessé de
l'enseignement qui vous à qui vous a
déçu oui c'est la méthode la pédagogie
du prof
c'est très français s'est d'ailleurs de
pas savoir valoriser un enfant et donc
j'étais pas très bon à l'école mais je
n'étais pas assez fort en maths essayer
de comprendre pourquoi pourquoi parce
que je n'ai que parlement français quand
je levé la main pour poser une question
la prof a été fort blues - alors allez-y
poser de questions alors quand max était
à saint michel
s'il vous plaît ce silence on écoute
jean michel ribes saison dix mais
comment est ce que on peut envoyer une
telle différence de messages selon le
propre
alors je suis devenu fort en maths alors
je sais pas si je suis une forme être
forcément positif
oui mais mais mais quand même je me suis
dit je me suis pour tous les français
enfin bon il faut changer ça quoi et
j'ai quitté les coaches krejci ibm mais
sur deux saisons et puis après vous avez
repris vos études on va continuer à
regarder ça après cette scolarité
interrompue il reprend ses études il
deviendra docteur en psychologie sociale
et ingénieur de recherche à l'éducation
nationale mais surtout il fonde une pme
qui emploie 25 personnes et créé des
logiciels de gestion de ressources
humaines
une entreprise innovante qui reçoit
d'ailleurs un soft d'or récompense
attribuée à ce qu'on n'appelait pas
encore les startups l'entreprise marche
bien mais un contrôle fiscal la
fragilise d'administration peut donc
sanctionné une entreprise qui investit
dans la recherche et personne ne peut
s'opposer à la toute puissance des
fonctionnaires
c'est donc pour se battre contre des
décisions qu'il estime à juste qu'ils
entrent comme on dit en politique
alors on va on va écouter nicolas david
dans un instant b c'est bien ça cesse et
c'est cette injustice quand il vous
aurait dit comment on peut changer les
choses quoi oui mais surtout
le fait de voir que l'état dit la
recherche
vous avez joué 25 personnes dont la
moitié étaient des chercheurs vous ne
pouvez pas déduire comme le crédit impôt
recherche le permettait la partie le
numérique le beurre la partie numéraire
et nérac la recherche c'est le premier
des multiplicateurs d'intelligence
d'innovation au monde
on est content l'état qui vous dit à ce
moment là non ce n'est pas imputable et
smain jour redresse j'ai une petite
fille de trois ans toutes les start of
the lights et à queue et donc il ya un
sentiment d'injustice quoi c'est ça de
deuil jeudi va continuer comment il se
dit que l'état soit aussi décalés des
réalités de l'entreprise
nous on avance on fait avancer le monde
occitan et tous mes copains qui sont
aussi bien sûr en bété comme ça ils me
disent que comme on a parlé de moi parce
que j'ai eu le soft de relationnel
examen alors guide bas coût puisque tu
as fait beaucoup de médias vas-y bon et
est pris en étau comme député et comme
ça alors on écoute nicolas mainville et
on parle justement jean michel fourgous
il s'est engagé en politique parce que
c'est un chef d'entreprise qui a vécu de
manière très concrète
je dirais les affres d'une
administration qui parfois est plus
punitives que facilitatrice pour les
chefs d'entreprise il s'engage donc et
il mène le combat
nous sommes en 1993 ce sera bientôt
l'heure de la deuxième cohabitation
la droite va triompher le ps s'effondrer
et comme jacques chirac
échaudé par l'expérience de 1986 ne veut
plus entendre parler de matignon
françois mitterrand va nommer edouard
balladur premier ministre
mais si la droite est favorite dans
certaines circonscriptions elle est
aussi divisée cela dit comme en france
tout marche par deux la gauche s'y est
al ces désaccords
le casting de cette élection est
impressionnant à gauche ni malandain
député sortant représente le parti
socialiste harlem désir qui deviendra le
premier secrétaire de ce même parti
porte pour l'heure les couleurs de
génération écologie nicolas bour maire
de montigny qui était député de la 8e
circonscription et qui deviendra par la
suite
sénateurs puis membre du csa et candidat
dissident unef à droite c'est jeanine
cahier conseillère municipale de trappes
membres du parti républicain qui obtient
lors de ce premier tour
l'investiture de l'ue pf c'est à dire de
la majorité udf rpr et dans cette
élection personne ne voit venir
ce candidat encore inconnue et nouveau
politique qui s'appelle jean-michel
fourgous et qui pendant sa campagne
parle essentiellement d'entreprises et
d'emplois
pourtant au premier tour énorme surprise
avec moins de 200 voix d'avancé sur
jeanne in cahiers il est le mieux placé
des candidats de la droite la campagne
cependant a été rude et les morceaux ne
seront pas faciles à reconnaître
sur son bulletin de vote il avait fait
apparaître en très gros rpr udf
ce qui était un moyen de laisser
imaginer aux électeurs qu'il était lui
même le candidat de l'udf mon communiqué
est clair à titre personnel je ne
voterai pas pour monsieur fourgous mais
je ne voterai pas non plus pour nous
c'est malandain jean michel fourgous se
reconnaît d'ailleurs que le combat n'a
pas été de tout repos
c'est vrai que c'était un petit peu
qu'une fois conflictuelle mais bon les
électeurs ont tranché
l'accès c'est ça la règle démocratique
s'est pas uniquement les partis qui font
qu'ils font les élections on reconnaît
le personnage plein de plats de courage
beaucoup de avec beaucoup de volonté de
détermination
et puis un peu j'en veux dire avec du
pif
c'est à dire qu'il avait senti que cette
circonscription pour en faire quelque
chose et donc il est parti tout seul
et comme il est arrivé au premier tour
je crois que tu as fait un très bon
score au premier tour en 1993
bien évidemment une investiture entre
les deux tours le ps lui apporte donc
son soutien entre les deux tours et
c'est jacques toubon qui viendra faire
campagne avec lui
le résultat sera des plus serrés 59 97%
fourgous 49,03 ballon d'un soit 616 voix
d'écart deux députés sortants semblent
faire contre mauvaise fortune bon coeur
la politique c'est comme ça ce sont des
victoires et des défaites il faut jamais
attendre en politique le remerciement de
ce qu'on a fait pour ses concitoyens
dans l'immédiat je vais chercher du
travail
lors de cette législative pour quelques
40 voix la ville d'elancourt est passé à
droite
c'est sans doute ce qui va convaincre
jean-michel fourgous de se présenter
deux ans plus tard contre le maire
socialiste alain d'années dans un
premier temps celui-ci remporté les
élections mais le scrutin est annulé et
les deux hommes se retrouvent à nouveau
face à face au début de l'année 1996 et
cette fois c'est jean michel fourgous
qui avec 123 voix d'avancé remporte le
combat
évidemment la courte victoire laissera
quelques traces au point que le nouveau
maire propose une commission municipale
ouverte à l'opposition
merci à tous parce que vous êtes des
élèves étaient difficiles et j'ai aussi
vous dire devant le sénat fait
effectivement un tirage est sur une
courbe est difficile je sais bien que
moi je propose du gars qui est une
transparence sont différentes
la position exprimée et bien vérifier
l'information
il ya dans cette campagne alors juste
juste petit possible quand vous êtes
présenté aux législatives
pourquoi vous avez choisi d'abord cette
circonscription est est ce que vous
aviez le sentiment que vous pouviez
gagner d'abord que j'avais moi j'avais
des certitudes j'avais des convictions
cimenté dans l'épreuve de l'expérience
et de cette échelle que m'avait fait
vivre un peu l'administration
ça vous donne et ce sentiment de de la
justice une force extraordinaire mais
vous aviez regardé politiquement comment
ça vous trouvez ce passant la direction
oui mais ça vous investissiez toi alors
en fait c'est un peu ambigu cette
histoire mais ça peut oublier en fait on
me l'avait donné la prévision ensuite on
là parce que il ya un autre dirigeant
qui voulait brûler les deux instituts
ribaute style aucune chance aux bouchons
leur enlèvement mais comme quoi bon oui
mais je dirais c'était parce que cette
séquence option y avait beaucoup de pme
moi je venais de la paix m ma femme dire
ma femme aussi a avait aussi un penny et
loyaux on était vraiment complètement
imprégné de cette culture qui qui fait
donner le meilleur de soi aux hommes
dans les petites entreprises
les rapports sont très direct vous voyez
les réalités c'est pas lui c'est pas du
blabla et et ça je sentais que cette
circoncis ressembler vous l'avez choisi
et puis après il va y avoir la mairie de
laon couvron côté de la regarder de
combat difficile non mais finalement
deux succès que le ton en tout cas pour
la mairie d'elancourt va pérenniser le
scrutin qui va arriver après doit nous
permettre de nous représenter surtout
date élu dès le premier tour
donc ce qui veut dire que les airs
comptoir était séduit quand même perdre
notre méthode par la méthode ainsi jean
charles pauze comment expliquer
d'ailleurs cette sorte de fidélité de
ses électeurs est lent courtois je pense
que la première des vertus de jean
michel fourgous qui explique l'ensemble
de ces élections
depuis effectivement sa toute première
élection acquise
dans la douleur c'est sa capacité de
savoir s'entourer deux aspects chez lui
important d'abord c'est un visionnaire
c'est à dire que c'est plus un homme de
grands dossiers mais de perspectives il
a été le premier par exemple avoir tout
l'intérêt du digital dans l'enseignement
il a été le premier à voir tout
l'intérêt de reconstruire un
commissariat et on voit bien aujourd'hui
dans l'actualité ce que représente
l'importance pour les forces de l'ordre
d'avoir un comessa digne de ce nom de
couvrir un territoire c'est un homme de
couverture plus généraliste et de vision
et de vision j'allais dire nationale
voire internationale
je prendrai le cas de l'impôt recherche
et en même temps ce qui explique que
localement il est toujours été réélu
c'est que c'est un homme qui sait
s'entourer d'hommes et de femmes de
terrain ce sont les équipes qui sont
avec lui qu'il a su bâtir renouveler
changé m aux affaires qui lui assure
effectivement cette réélection est
d'ailleurs jeu direct dans une ville qui
est plutôt j'allais dire de tentations
plutôt de gauche il est réélu alors que
c'est un homme de droite on voit bien là
que c'est la gestion du terrain qui lui
permet cette réflexion brillante au
premier tour à chaque fois le succès ne
s'est un peu le même aux élections
législatives on se souvient de la
dissolution décidée par jacques chirac
en 1997
ce qui fera dire aux mauvaises langues
qui vient d'inventer le septennat de
deux ans la vague rose qui va amener
lionel jospin à matignon est cette fois
trop forte pour quelque 560 trois voix
catherine tasca remporté l'élection
c'est bien la preuve que cette 11e
circonscription est un peu particulière
c'est une circonscription assez
difficile qui qui prend le vent comme on
dit en politique c'est à dire quand il
ya une élection présidentielle en
général le député et de la couleur
politique de l'élection présidentielle
récente donc pourquoi c'est une vraie
question parce que il n'y a pas beaucoup
de circonscriptions comme ça dans la
noue dans la dans les yvelines dans le
département je pense mois plus tôt c'est
sa sociologie céline sociologie très
coupée en deux avec d'un côté une partie
plus tôt on va dire versailles grand
parc et une partie plutôt ville nouvelle
et donc il ya très très très fort
équilibre gagne très bonne balance qui
s'effectue alors cette balance elle peut
pencher d'un côté elle peut elle peut
pencher de l'autre le balance il
continuera 2002 réélection de jacques
chirac et victoire de jean michel fau
2007 victoire de nicolas sarkozy et
réélection de jean michel fourgous 2012
élection de françois hollande et dans la
11e circonscription de benoît hamon 2017
l'élection d' emmanuel macron
s'accompagne d'un raz-de-marée des
candidats north marche dont bénéficient
nadia et celle ci devenu ministre de la
ville devra toutefois abandonner son
siège et lors d'une élection partielle
c'est philippe benassaya candidat du pnr
qui donc forte aura juste un mot sur
sept c'est vrai c'est ce d'une
circonscription assez particulière dans
les yvelines un il ya des
circonscriptions qui sont alors il le
raz-de-marée macro nist en 2017 et un
peu particulier mais sinon il des
circonscriptions vision plutôt à droite
et celle là elle elle balance en
fonction de la tendance polymathique
national systématique
c'est étonnant quand même un set vous
avez donc ça dépend pas de votre bilan
dont une partie sera des prix du coton
les 6 et 10 c'était une circonscription
très difficile et c'est pour ça que ont
mal joué c'est pas trop embêté ce que je
me suis présentée plus ou moins on
savait pas vraiment l'investiture bon et
on m'a quand même
entre guillemets et les cv c'est aussi
avant le sais pas ce que parce qu'il
pensait que chance d'abord cogné 13 de
reagan l'avait jamais été
voilà c'est telle ou telle est l île
peuplée pénurie aux côtés du voilà pour
les combats politiques les élections les
campagnes intéressant d'ailleurs de
savoir comment cet homme qui se méfie du
superficiel qui préfère parler et
convaincre plutôt que de serrer des
mains fait campagne
ce qui est terrible jean michel fourgous
et que nous nous faisons beaucoup de
porte à porte
d'ailleurs c'est la meilleure des écoles
je veux dire de commerce pratiquement
c'est une élection municipale à
elancourt nous allons voir 100 % des
habitants chez eux en période électorale
et lorsque l'on fait ses campagnes avec
jean michel fourgous on voit toute la
paix tant ce qu'il a dans ses opérations
de porte à porte
tant et si bien que cantons suisses un
objectif de voir 31 ans courtois quand
on arrive à en faire deux avec lui c'est
du monde est en elle et qui les a
tendance à rester pendant une heure une
heure et quart à discuter avec les gens
a alors apporté la contradiction au
contraire les rassurer du coup on fait
moins de portes vous voyez ce il a ce
côté passionnel du discours et du
dialogue avec les autres actifs du coup
montre son appétence pour les campagnes
toral et je dirais qu'il adore un peu le
doro également ce combat rhétorique bien
souvent il va aller chercher notre
position en conseil municipal
mais pour pouvoir essayer de les
persuader en fait il ne renonce jamais à
persuader y compris ses plus farouches
opposants
il aurait peut-être d'ailleurs pu tenter
de reconquérir ce siège de député
aujourd'hui le mandat unique l'empêchera
peut-être de se représenter bien que
quelque part il en a envie mais il fait
un travail tellement extraordinaire dans
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines qu' il est déjà très pris par
ce mandat je pense que jean michel
fourgous appris aujourd'hui la la juste
mesure du rôle de ce qu'est un président
d'une communauté d'agglomération comme
saint quentin en yvelines de tout ce qui
lie à faire du côté passionnant il a
fait un grand nombre de mandats à un
nombre important de mandat en tant que
député il a également pu prendre bien
entendu là la tendance et se rendre
compte concrètement de ce que l'on
pouvait faire entendre députés pour moi
il est passé à autre chose
il est passé d'une phase où on va
proposer des lois on va modifier ses
lois on va les amender ce sont des lois
très généraliste je pense qu'il a fait
son temps sur ce sujet là et qu'il a
voulu revenir à des choses beaucoup plus
concrète et jallet dit
que et j'allais dire que et je suis
désolé pour mes amis députés ça ne
plaira pas forcément un président de
deux pci de communes d'agglomération de
métropole aujourd'hui deux communautés
de communes a plus probablement de
pouvoir pour le coup à faire
concrètement sur le terrain à à
anticiper à agir qu'un député qu'il va
bien souvent levé la main avec ses 200
autres collègues pour adopter un
amendement qu'il aura écrit ou qu'il
aura porté mais qui sera longue et un
peu dans une masse
je veux redire là sur cette saison
olivier dassault dip
peut-être qu'il aurait bien aimé devenir
député le rom aux rides dit non
finalement c'est peut-être plus concret
ce que vous pouvez faire sur un
territoire que qu'à l'assemblée doit
absolument sûr devienne député mais
j'étais à côté de lui un voile a fait un
bond ensemble seulement 250 députés
aujourd'hui à 100 quand j'étais
président après donc il faut débuter
pour les présentes séries qui du
président il m'a tout de suite nommé
héritage bien leur faire très très réglo
dire et il a monté à 150
alors ça ne l'était pas mais c'est très
joli dit oui mais quand il fait un
voyage avec des lits des falcons cesu à
des oui non mais ils adorent habillé
super-g groupe qui est d'ailleurs sur le
fric et de nulle part un affidé ans
c'est vrai que quand on est député alors
même si on va revenir sur des choses que
vous avez fait dans l'amendement
fourgous ans et c'est un oui mais il
avait joué un rôle important va en
parler mais mais c'est vrai qu'on est un
parmi d'autres quand on est président
d'une
l'agglomération saint quentin maires des
villes on voit peut-être plus
directement le fruit de son action non
no border camp président d'une
agglomération comme saint quentin en
yvelines
honnêtement il faut le dire c'est un
petit joyau exécutif ça n'a rien à voir
avec les députés dans l'opposition déjà
les députés n'ont pu freiner leur donner
la parole
il n'y a que 2 % des lois qui sont fait
parler sur l'inspiration des députés
donc voilà ici
ici nous avons une équipe qui tient la
route une cohérence des très belles
entreprises abonnés d'alice prix est la
preuve
moi j'ai même donné des postes de
vice-président à tout le monde et
l'arrivée
et ça fonctionne récente voilà vous avez
plus de jeu le dire c'est un mot un peu
compliqué moi vous êtes autre atout
psychologique
il est plus heureux n'ai rien à voir
j'ai été trois fois député mais
aujourd'hui le député
vous avez une buvette son peuple pour
les copains et puis le rectangle du
huitième étage et puis des voyageant en
classe affaires pour faire le tour du
monde bon franchement c'est bon c'est
pas mon truc
par contre fait réussi à la crise crée
des emplois d'avenir de stratégie miex
ça c'est vraiment l'avenir de la france
c'est le plus grand des multiples
numérique c'est le plus grand des
multiplicateurs d'innovation
d'intelligence de 2 de croissance dieu
sait si on a besoin de croissance pour
rembourser les dettes pour pour redonner
ce pays toute la vigueur qu'il aurait
jamais dû perdre mais voilà donc moi
aussi je suis très heureux alors
justement on va parler du fond de votre
engagement
peut-être en effet cette passion du
concret s'exprime-t-elle plus
directement à la tête d'une mairie ou
d'une agglomération que dans une
majorité parlementaire est cependant
avec génération entreprises associations
de parlementaire créée avec olivier
dassault hervé novelli associations ont
des passes des clivages politiques
il est parvenu à convaincre des députés
jusqu'à l'heure ces petits de
s'intéresser au monde des entrepreneurs
il a créé effectivement avec olivier
dassault et hervé novelli à l'époque ce
groupe de deux députés issus du monde de
l'entreprise qui sont très minoritaire à
l'assemblée nationale qui est un monde
dont les députés représenter en tout cas
à l'époque davantage le monde
administratif et il a créé ce groupe là
pour essayer de changer les choses
changer concrètement les lois génération
entreprise c'est une une force
d'intervention c'est aussi une
passerelle tout simplement entre le
monde politique et le monde économique
ou entre le monde économique et le monde
que nous parmi les textes portés par
génération entreprise
il y en a un qui est presque devenu un
nom commun puisque on dit qu'on peut
fourgous et son assurance vie et c'est
l'amendement fourgous
c'est vrai que l'amendement que nous
avons co signé et ce qui nous fait
toujours sourire et jean-michel parce
qu'il porte le nom du premier signataire
donc très gentiment on le présente comme
la demande m'en fous rouge d'assaut
c'est l'amendement fourgous et donc ça a
été très importante pour revitaliser le
tissu industriel précisions sur le sur
les chiffres c'est 100 milliards pour
l'année sur 100 biens donc et est lié
cette fin fond du problème et puisque
c'est en fait entre 500 millions et 1
milliard mais parce que ça provoque des
tours de table donc vous arriviez avec
collier cette pme le mec donc il arrive
et hop ça déclenche et en même temps du
tour de table dès que vous arrivez avec
des bons mais déjà l'importance
circulation l'assurance-vie fédération
des actions de lutte bien plus de sens
ni vernis au micron ge
on doit être à 110 n'est plus de 100
milliards c'est le moment que celle où
la grosseur fourgous d'origine
parlementaire est d'origine
parlementaire est sûre une fois que ce
truc parce que est il du sang sur les
murs pour faire passer ça vraiment vous
l'ayez ça a été une révolution
les petites figurines finances n'y
croyais pas et est utilisée de quoi il
va ruiner le budget français
il va prendre l'argent de l'épargné mais
c'est nous à bercy parce que quand des
finances ségeron îles éparses qui
garantisse la dette comme ça ils peuvent
endetté le pays
ils ont ils utilisent la garantie de 2
ne l'est pas une défense elles dont je
dis non l'épargné français une partie
dit vous allez renforcer le capital de
nos entreprises en produisant des sons
deux à quatre fois moins capitalisées
que leurs concurrents anglais a le moins
bien donc c'était sale et on a réussi
mais vous avez réussi malgré merci aux
faut il faut il faut s'imposer quoi
parce qu'il à bercy parce qu'il ya une
ouïe et d'administration très forte avec
des gens très diplômés des inspecteurs
des filles dans cette série mais qui
tiennent au fond percer ici on s'impose
pas et d'ailleurs tous ceux qui ont été
ministres de l'économie le 10 ans ils
n'arrivent pas à s'imposer très vite
après ces fichus quoi
mais le foie de lugny à jouer parce que
moi il était tout seul match d'evian
pilot groupe parlementaire oui c'est ça
tout ça à plat aujourd'hui serait jamais
passé à ut1 on serait jamais vous écoute
nicolas david qui donne des précisions
justement isf pme pour que l'argent des
riches comme on dit financent les
les petites entreprises et puis le
crédit impôt-recherche le crédit impôt
recherche
on s'est battu avec jean michel fourgous
depuis 1995
avant même génération entreprise existe
déjà en 95 et à l'époque l'étions en
trois ans avec hervé novelli
et lorsque nous avons recréé en 2002
après la défaite 97 lorsque nous sommes
revenus au parlement nous nous sommes
battus pour élargir l'assiette de ce
crédit impôt recherche et surtout le
faire perdurer au delà des majorités et
là c'est quelque chose qui a été
formidablement encourager et nous a
fallu 12 ans de bataille sur ce sujet et
c'est en 2008 que nicolas sarkozy lui
donne sa véritable dimension dimension
qui a perduré sous françois hollande est
également sourds emmanuel macron une
précision sur ce que dit olivier
dassault qui parle de nicolas sarkozy à
l'époque la ministre de la recherche
c'est valérie pécresse oui de diversité
de la recherche louis je vous prendrai
louis lui je fais et ancien patron de
renault
10 est la meilleure le très bien pour
recherche c'est la meilleure mesure
politique qui était prise dans les 15
années et il faut le rappeler
certes génération entreprise d'assaut
fourgous voilà aimé mais c'est pécresse
ministre de la recherche qui nous
autorise vraiment à faire passer et qui
est qui qui fait passer la
transformation multiplie par dix le
crédit impôt recherche pour les
entreprises comme beaucoup de chercheurs
et s'abaisse l'équivalent des charges
patronales et savoureux mais un même
niveau que que les autres pays et l'art
devient compétitif l'intelligence on a
protégé l'intelligence française les les
brevets c'est une wii parce que la
recherche est essentielle enfin et c'est
grâce à petric faut bien ok autre cheval
de bataille de jean michel fourgous le
numérique
à l'époque anne k piou qui deviendra
ensuite adjointe au maire d'elancourt et
conseillère départementale spécialiste
de jean ducasse tour dirigé
l'association des parents d'élèves
il m'a demandé si j'étais d'accord pour
diriger une association qu'il a manqué à
l'époque s'appelait initiative terrain
et qui avait pour objet de développer
justement le numérique dans les
apprentissages scolaires
on a travaillé avec un laboratoire de
lyon qui a développé un logiciel qui
s'imprime mémo zor et qui développe et
les différentes facettes de la mémoire
donc oddity
visuel etc donc on est parti au départ
sur ce projet là où on à équiper l'école
qui était l'école des petits prêts à
elancourt dans un quartier un petit peu
compliqué à l'époque et on a équipé une
salle avec 25 ordinateurs à l'époque je
pense souviens c'était noël avant
l'heure parce qu'on avait on a mis une
vraiment beaucoup de matériel et on a
fait travailler différents groupes sur
sur ce sur ce logiciel
on a fait un certain nombre d'auditions
pour essayer de voir comment ces
nouveaux outils pédagogiques pouvait
améliorer le plaisir d'apprendre le
plaisir d'enseigner et augmenter les
résultats scolaires de tous nos enfants
il faut peut-être préciser ceci que ce
qui nous paraît aujourd'hui aller de soi
était dans les années 90 assez novateur
à l'époque jean michel fourgous quand il
parle du numérique à l'école
tout le monde le prend pour un
hurluberlu c'est effectivement ça des
cas ça ça décoiffe c'est vraiment une
innovation dont on a très très peu
entendu parler et il va prendre ce thème
à bras le corps je crois que à l'époque
une enseignante l'avait dit voilà il
faudra me me passer sur le corps pour
mettre en place ces outils numériques
dans nombre d'établissements moins
vivant que jamais et au final tout le
monde a suivi mais c'est vrai qu'il a
été un vrai père précurseur ils sont
dessaisis avec un esprit d'innovation
pour que chacun que tous les acteurs de
l'éducation se rendent compte de
l'importance du numérique mais de
l'innovation à l'école de manière
générale et aujourd'hui je dirais le
l'idée était considéré comme farfelu
puis innovantes et puis maintenant c'est
une idée très répandue et dont beaucoup
de villes de france s'en empare avec
beaucoup de réussite et de bien dire que
là vous voyez l'égalité des chances
c'est gai c'est que que le prof vous
trouve sympathique ou pas vous avez un
outil devant vous vous pouvez apprendre
à votre rythme revoir le soir etc c'est
complètement différent
est ce l'effet pygmalion non je vous ai
parlé après et et c'est extra dire et
c'est le meilleur outil pour lutter
contre l'échec scolaire
c'est pour ça qu'ils montrent les
scolaires contre les inégalités
d'origine parce que c'est vrai que ça
fait sauter des des classes presque à
déduire un aux enfants les plus qui sort
de milieux défavorisés
c'est à celle des fautes qu'on peut dire
c'est que on le voit prendre un élan
course à dupuy même plus dix ans c'est
qu'on fait fin après la terminale
baccalauréat on convoque les on invite
les jeunes qui ont passé leur bac avec
mention bon et on s'aperçoit que la
honte ils ont une orientation
professionnelle ils ont décidé du nom de
ce modèle qui est très scientifique
tony cotte ça stimule la culture
scientifique discret c'est indiscutable
alors il me faut des cottagers reptilien
superexperts mai mais ben écoutez je
pense que si c'est le seul crédit qu'on
veut faire écouter jaspal un bond à
paris saclay ou plus qui peut les
accuser universités scientifiques et
techniciens au monde
voilà une cohérence et corée il était
persuadé que en amenant le numérique
dans les apprentissages scolaires il a
vite compris que ça a mené une autonomie
d'enseignement on n'apprend pas tous au
même rythme on est d'accord donc le
numérique permet l'autonomie des élèves
et permettent de travailler à son rythme
et selon ses compétences
deux missions parlementaires seront
consacrés au sujet j'ai participé avec
jean michel fourgous à 2 2 deux missions
parlementaires une en 2009 qui était le
thème c'était la porte de l'outil
numérique
dans l'informatique et à l'époque
effectivement on avait rencontré jean
michel blanquer air il était à l'époque
directeur de la dgesco au ministère et
voilà vous avez bien aidé d'ailleurs
dans dans les différentes conversations
qu'on avait eue avec lui et la deuxième
mission parlementaire c'était en 2011 et
là c'était bon maintenant on a prouvé
que l'apport du numérique dans les
apprentissages scolaires était déficient
maintenant on va on va on va adapter la
pédagogie à l'outil informatique
on apprend plus les enseignants en
apprendre plus aux élèves en classe
pareil avec le tout numérique amendement
rapport parlementaire est toujours de
fortes convictions
la première qu'il faut moderniser le
pays et que l'utilisation des outils
numériques va permettre de faire
franchir une étape et aussi de gommer en
partie des inégalités sociales la
seconde qu'il faut laisser des chefs
d'entreprise créer une richesse dont
tout le monde profitera deux idées
fortes qu'il va pouvoir mettre en oeuvre
sur ce territoire
c'était pas quelqu'un hors sol qui
parlait de grandes idées nationales
il a toujours essayé de mettre en
pratique au local et notamment à
elancourt puis à l'échelle de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines les grandes
idées qu'il défend des c'était le cas
avec le numérique
certes il y avait la mission
parlementaire au niveau national mais y
avait je dirais à elancourt le
laboratoire d'innovation réel et c'est
pareil au niveau économique il défend
des des grandes idées sur l'entreprise
sur l'entrepreneuriat sur l'innovation
mais il a pu les mettre en pratique en
tant que vice président de saint quentin
en yvelines au développement économique
et ensuite de président de saint quentin
en yvelines avec la création du ch'ti
cube pour avoir ce guichet unique pour
nos entrepreneurs avec la soirée des
entrepreneurs pour pour essayer tous les
ans de de promouvoir je dirais les
bonnes idées à mettre en pratique pour
nos entrepreneurs de renforcer le
sentiment d'appartenance pour deux chefs
d'entreprises sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines
et puis là on l'a vu aussi sur les
écoles du numérique l'ouverture des
écoles de formation au numérique
pour des profils qui sont pas forcément
diplômés qui sont parfois en décrochage
parfois il suit nos quartiers et pour
qu'il puisse avoir une formation sur des
métiers qui sont très recruteurs mais
donc c'est effectivement moi ce que j'ai
beaucoup apprécié chez l'homme jean
michel fourgous c'est qu'il ya les idées
il ya le combat qui mais de manière très
très pugnace mais il ya aussi la
réalisation le concret tantôt de dresser
un bilan
homme de droite libérale la réalité est
peut-être plus complexe ce n'est pas un
ultralibéral cc c'est un homme qui pense
que les idéaux libéraux peuvent aider la
république l'état et que le service
public peut aussi aider le l'entreprise
le privé et donc c'est cette alchimie là
qu'il essaye depuis des années de
produire dans notre pays
c'est un libéral c'est un homme de
droite c'est un homme qui a la foi
libérale mais néanmoins qui est plutôt
de droite sociale
j'ai à dire c'est un homme qui est assez
complet et si je voulais un petit rien
pu que j'avais même que on l'a vu sur le
par exemple d'édition culturel on
pourrait dire que ça peut même être un
homme de gauche
d'ailleurs la gouvernance qu'il pratique
est à cent lieues des affrontements des
premières campagnes puisque sur les
quinze vice-présidents de saint quentin
en yvelines quatre appartiennent à
l'opposition un saint quentin en
yvelines jean michel fourgous s'est
révélé comme j'allais dire pratiquement
un homme du centre mais au bon sens du
terme capable de composer avec tous deux
donné il a été quasiment le premier à le
faire des vice-présidences à ces
oppositions de travailler au quotidien
avec elle donc c'est un très bon exemple
lors d'un certain qu'on revienne
là-dessus parce que c'est vrai que à un
moment vous avez pu avoir une image un
peu pas tellement consensuelle et au
fond quand vous êtes comme d'être
président de saint quentin vous avez
fait venir il ya quatre vice présidents
qui sont des élus de l'opposition qui
travaillent avec nous tous et moyennes
entreprises jeu plus un entrepôt league
l'entreprise vous gates ce qui est bien
ce qui est mal ce qui est vrai et ce qui
est faux il ya beaucoup moins de jeu
qu'on peut trouver avec une dialectique
très très politicienne franco français
sur je me retrouve pas la suisse pour
sakho comme shop direct 8 il est un peu
bon mais oui voilà par exemple vous me
connaissez vrai déclic toutes les
communes de gauche et droite sont
représentés voilà c'est la première fois
que ils ont ils ont des vice présidents
et vice-présidents c'est pas et paris
mais pas de là moi je l'aimé parce que
je pense que c'est quand vous faites
confiance aux gens à mes trois enfants
j'en ai trois joueurs je leur fais
confiance aux d'antan il faut affirmer
mais et c'est pour ça que vous dis-je
parce que la droite la gauche mais c'est
vrai que j'ai l'impression que la droite
fait fait confiance d'abord fait
confiance à l'entreprise que c'est le
lieu où où un homme qui a une idée
rencontre un homme cas de l'argent à un
homme qui valait faire un réseau
commercial va cesser c'est comme ça que
vous créez et vous trouvez des
meilleures solutions que celles qui
existent pour la vie des gens pour
améliorer la vie des gens et c'est vrai
que c'est un laboratoire extraordinaire
pour développer l'intelligence humaine
sont changés responsable donc donc voilà
je sais pas si c'est ça être libéral
mais il faut donner une liberté minimum
minimum est ce qu'un enfant il faut
fixer des règles mais il ya des rémois
je suis très laide sua et concept gauche
de droite du centre je m'en fous je
réalise a été volé ainsi va la vie au
quotidien
faire de la politique pour convaincre
dont convaincre de l'importance de
convertir notre pays à la révolution
numérique et de faciliter la vie des
entrepreneurs parce que ce sont eux qui
créent la richesse
et faire de la politique autrement qu'en
adoptant des textes préparés pas de
jeunes fonctionnaires sortie tout frais
de l'ena mais qui n'ont aucune
expérience du terrain consacrera
d'ailleurs à cette mainmise de la haute
administration sur la politique
un livre virulent écrit avec gregor
bourgeois jean michel fourgous plaide
d'ailleurs avec d'autres et qui sortent
de plus en plus nombreux pour la
suppression de cette école il renâcle
un peu comme moi sur sur cette formation
unique qu'elena pourparlers pour les
fonctionnaires et il a raison je pense
que l'école nationale administration
n'est plus adaptée aux enjeux
d'aujourd'hui
faire de la politique autrement c'est
aussi s'entourer de personnalités très
diverses et mettre le pied à l'étrier à
la nouvelle génération
c'est quelqu'un qui décloisonne qui
n'est pas dans une logique de hiérarchie
ou de verticalité il est beaucoup plus
horizontale il implique beaucoup ses
équipes dans ces rendez vous dans ces
projets il s'entoure de gens très très
différents quel que soit parfois même
leurs idées politiques ou leurs origines
il aime avoir une équipe de genres
différents et me disait toujours le
meilleur talent c'est de trouver les
talents exemple de l'actuel député de la
11e circonscription qui fut le directeur
de la communication de la ville des noms
j'ai été sollicité dans un premier temps
par la ville d'elancourt pour travailler
collaborer sur des sujets de
communication voilà comme un client si
vous voulez à l'origine et puis cette
sas et au fil de nos conversations avec
jean michel fort où je me souviens sont
proches le premier rendez vous qu'on a
eue c'était la buvette de l'assemblée
nationale un soir il doit être entre
deux séances je sais de quoi je parle
on va souvent la buvette pour pour entre
deux entre deux séances et il et il m'a
dit voilà si je pouvais éventuellement
aller plus loin qu'une simple
collaboration entre clients et agences
et j'ai accepté j'ai accepté parce qu'à
l'époque et l'encours était dans une
dynamique numérique une dynamique
vraiment politique intéressante et
serrage accepté pour conclure laissons
la parole deux personnalités
incontournables et de ce territoire et
de la politique française
d'abord la présidente de la région ile
de france valérie pécresse
ils portent des fabuleux projet
pour l'avenir le projet de la colline
d'elancourt qui va devenir la colline du
vélo en ile-de-france et en france ce
sont des magnifiques projets et je ne
vous parle pas évidemment de toute
l'éducation numérique que nous déployons
lui dans les collèges et les écoles et
moi dans les lycées de la case qui est
des yvelines ensuite gérard larcher
président du sénat je le connais bien
d'abord c'est un homme qui pensent que
l'économie c'est quelque chose
d'essentiel et qu'on ne bâtit rien sans
une économie qui tient debout il a pas
tort vous ne luttez pas contre la
pauvreté vous ne lui étaient pas contre
le chômage
vous n'avez pas des progrès dans la
société sans une économie qui soit
soutenue c'est un homme qui croit aussi
dans les vertus de la science moi aussi
et en ces temps où nous voyons que nous
avons besoin de la science pour nous
sortir de la pandémie et de maladie je
crois que ça fait partie de ces valeurs
c'est un homme en plus extrêmement
présents sur le terrain extrêmement
enracinés dans dans sa ville d'elancourt
au fond c'est ta mère c'est aussi un
homme qui a une vision nationale
notamment vu au plan économique mais
aussi très attentif à son territoire
alors il est plutôt d'une pièce parfois
mais ça fait partie de ses qualités
et moi je les ai toujours soutenu on ne
se ressemblent pas tout à fait
c'est vrai et je dois dire que c'est une
chance là aussi pour ce territoire à la
communauté d'agglomération de saint
quentin qui puisse faire partie comme
chef d'equipe de tout l'été qui cette
équipe de la communauté d'agglomération
de saint quentin on ne se ressemblent
pas dit gérard larcher
c'est vrai que peut-être plus que
politique comme on l'entend généralement
que vous mais au fond il voit là il
reconnaît que l'action que vous avez
mené pour les entreprises pour le
numérique notamment c'est important et
que vous amenez aussi sur ce territoire
mais je suis moins rond qu il songe
dollars mais les sénateurs c'est quand
même beaucoup plus petit que moi je suis
beaucoup plus direct presque sujet verbe
complément dans l'entreprise en appel
mais ça m'a beaucoup marqué les pme
c'est qu'on se parle directement on se
raconte pas de blabla on cccc voilà
c'est pour cette quelquefois ça casse un
peu par rapport à la classe politique
traditionnelle
vous n'êtes pas des ronds de jambe et
est sûre sur la science à croire que moi
j'aime la science j'aime l'entreprise
mais j'aime la science de la passe un
doctorat si vous avez une formation
scientifique méthodologie brrr mais même
regarder mais même cette histoire de
l'ex1 alors tu viens du salon 3 c'est
vrai que vous avez vous allez terre des
premiers avec le vélodrome de saint
quentin a organisé une vaccination de
masse pour la population alors même
chose ouais moi aussi j'aime la science
ça c'est juste très très heureux
clément
oui et on fait quand vous regardez la
solution de la pandémie
c'est la science qui l'a trouvé en dix
mois en dix morts aujourd'hui des
vaccins alors qu'avant il fallait 5 à 10
heures bon ordinaire donc voilà alors
maintenant il s'agit de bien sûr de la
produire parce que c'est bien d'ailleurs
créé mais après faut sur la liste de
fausses il aurait ensuite et ensuite et
là où vous voyez une nouvelle fois
saint-quentin bien en innovation et
montre bien cette culture et tous les
élus suivent un cette culture
d'anticiper le vaccin il est là bon
gardien peut enfin il arrive elle arrive
la prochaine étape c'est quoi c'est un
peu ce qu'on va proposer à saint quentin
dans quelques semaines peut-être les
vaccins certes dans les meilleures
conditions mais en plus ça va être un
vaccin plus plus parce que c'est un bon
là on va en fait vous accompagner on va
faire un peu une étude d'impact je
reproche au député où il est parfois de
faire des lois et ne pas mesurer
l'impact après c'est dans une entreprise
vous avez le service après vente entre
guillemets vous soucier que de clients
il le bien le produit
et ben moi c'est ça qui m'intéresse que
le vrai débat ça va plus etre les accès
ce avec l'immunité
si vous avez une immunité qui dure que
trois mois que sait on que six mois au
que douze mois ou 12 mois on a besoin de
savoir qu'ils ont des bonnes soeurs
qu'elle varia pourquoi vous sur devant
le même bac c'est pourquoi vous auriez
plus d'immunité que moi ou contre un peu
importe et donc on est on va nous suivre
les gens tous les trois mois on va leur
faire une prise de sang voire voir un
peu le niveau
pendant leurs anticorps baisse ou pas
pour que vraiment on est une véritable
étude parce que c'est avec ça qu'on
pourra remettre les gens au travail dans
saint quentin est sûr mais pas les gens
au travail dans 50 ans on va avoir de
sacrés problèmes on a dix-sept mille
entreprises on a les plus gros pib par
habitant en france
vous imaginez que bien sûr que les
entrepreneurs tous les salariés ils en
ont marre aussi des déchets triés donc
c'est pas seulement le vaccin c'est un
vaccin qu'on que l'on dont on contrôler
l'efficacité c'est ça qu'on va avoir de
plus à saint quentin donc très
pratiquement on va se faire vacciner et
tous les trois mois
on pourra les faire une prise de sang au
vélodrome par exemple ce sera au
vélodrome
marcal on est en train de celle des
cadres elles vont être sûr qu'on a les
anticorps donc on ne risque pas
d'attraper le virus donc on peut aller
travailler qu'on peut vivre à peu près
normalement vous êtes favorable ou
passeport vaccinale par exemple pas du
tout façon si on veut être dans le sens
l'attendait roger pas encore reçu les
corps du lendemain du jeu l'est pour les
vaccins mais non la deuxième procès
qu'on veut rajouter on n'a pas besoin
d'avoir un accord du ministre à la santé
bon voilà pourquoi il ordonnerait pas
ces dames mais cela est donc donc ça
c'est vraiment ça c'est vraiment se
soucier de garantir oui de garantir
quelque chose de vrai sur votre métier
parce que si le type pense qu'il est
immunisé et oui les banques voilà qu'on
débite monde donc donc ça alors bien sûr
que le passeport
peu importe le terme oui ce que j'ai vu
que je n'étais pas ici on risque rime à
rien s'ils voulaient relancer les
théâtres et des cinémas les restaurants
mais bien entendu que que que celui qui
veut pas sur l'accident ok mais il va
falloir il va falloir clarifier les
choses parce qu'on va pas laisser mourir
l'économie de la culture tout ça parce
qu'il y en a un qui sur le go je
préférais un bon bref donc de toute
façon dans d'autres pays on y va on voit
bien qu'il n'ya pas le cas on n'a pas le
choix c'est même pas un choix affectif
au machin c'est une réalité il faut
remettre l'économie formelle la culture
il faut remettre tout en marche et bien
entendu le celui qui a on sait qu'il a
ces anticorps l'avait surpris les pas de
vivre normalement et on va remettre elle
est la vie normale dans la société
française et internationale je suis pas
le seul à partager ça là il ya une chose
très intéressante pendant cette crise
sanitaire
c'est là
ce sont les rapports entre l'état et au
fond les collectivités locales on a vu
que les collectivités locales c'était le
cas de saint quentin a pris en charge un
certain dos et a pris ses
responsabilités si vous le dire c'est
vous qui avez décidé d'ouvrir ce
vaccinodromes pour l'appeler comme ça
enfin dans le vélodrome alors que l'état
et pépette plus en plus réticents ne
savait pas tellement comment comment
faire elle s'est essayée de pouvoir
quoiqu'il y ait un problème dans ce pays
on va pas se le cacher c'est je cache
pas les problèmes fin je saigne et
trouver des solutions dans l'entreprise
on a la culture de la solution du musc
de les chercher un coupable comme on
veut et souvent politique ça ça pose
beaucoup de fautes trouver des solutions
l'état aujourd'hui l'état français il
devient presque dangereux pour la france
mais bon il a oublié qu'il est au
service de la france je rappelle que moi
je suis pas servi à l'état les têtes à
mon service on s'y met tous les mets
tous les maires les mains il a 35 mille
îles ont une le peuple est souverain et
les élus surtout les mères qui les
tribus ils ont cette souveraineté et
pour six ans donc quand on a quelquefois
un ministre qui s'expriment dont on sait
pas si dans six mois ou dans 12 mois
reese voilà il faudrait quand même
peut-être réapprendre le management un
peu plus horizontal ce que c'est
insupportable
les interventions des représentants de
l'état sur les logements sociaux mais
est ce que c'est à eux de gérer
c'est une gestion de proximité déjà de
gérer de gérer
logements sociaux il ya plein de choses
qui sont des décisions de proximité mais
qu'est ce qu'une espèce de tous mais qui
se mêlent déjà de ses missions
régaliennes
elles sont bien faites ses missions
régaliennes quand on a le la france qui
est le le pays où les impôts sont les
plus élevés au monde
le pays on travaille le moins au monde
tout ça parce que des gens qui se font
élire en disant aux gens avaient lieu
votez pour moi vous allez - travail
bâillon mais vous avez vu le le système
de santé qui est le plus déclassé le
système d'éducation avec pisa quelques
des classes et donc on peut pas
continuer comme ça donc l'état il va
falloir qu'il retrouve sa place et barco
qu'on arrête moi je ne veux plus voir
sur en dehors des missions régaliennes
voire dix représentants de l'état qui
interviennent comme ça sur les sur les
mers je peux vous dire on va on va
casser le il faut arrêter ça parce que
sinon le système va se casser entre eux
les élus qui ont une forte légitimité et
si les mêmes dans les sondages les élus
préférés les défaire c'est parce qu'ils
voient la réalité c'est pas parce qu'ils
sont il me voit il son soutien à leurs
clients qui sont dans leurs fantasmes
dans leur jeu intellectuel dans dans
science po l'ena je veux dire donc on
arrête je suis passé aussi par cette
école six ans qu un bon mais mais paul
est né sur bon donc voilà il faut il
faut redonner c'est la compétence qui
est qui qui est important est la
compétence ça n'existe pas sans
expérience donc tous ces gens qui
confondent un statut haut niveau de
l'état qu'on aurait donné d'ailleurs
quel est l'âge est légitime de tout ça
il ya que la compétence il faut que
l'état prouve sa valeur ajoutée
maintenant c'est un mais il faut il faut
il fait des études à paris et dans les
cabinets ministériels on veut 50% de
gens qui vivent dans l'entreprise on
veut 50 % des gens qui nous ressemblent
qui viennent de la production richesse
de la production de solutions répondent
ces jeux de dialectique de deux postures
de statut de stratégies de pouvoir
personnel ça il faut arrêter ça parce
que ce pays va être exposée sinon une
vraie révolution dont était que je vous
réconcilier le terrain c'est-à-dire les
maires avec avec avec l'état français
parce que sinon sa nature c'est que
l'état ne leur mette pas des bâtons
nous les coûts et que l'état et que
l'état soit accompagnateurs et ne pas et
non pas effacer des choses pour la
police sauf pour la justice mais laissez
ça c'est les fonctions régaliennes voile
mais il reste que c'est au maire de
décider c'est pas un état qui est
complètement déconnecté des réalités et
vous voyez sur les genoux ont décidé que
j'ai toute une histoire
donc voilà on aime bien tout le monde il
faut qu' il faut se réconcilier mais il
faut que l'état se réconcilie avec le
monde de l'entreprise qu'il ne
représente pas mais c'est quand même les
autres puisque après les élections et la
richesse et les collectivités locales et
territoriales bien qu'ils aient eux sont
dans la réalité vous regrettez en un mot
la emmanuel macron n'ait pas été au bout
de sa province n'est pas supprimer les
notes mais comme d'habitude il dit une
belle phrase avec des jolis mots il
parle très bien je souffre fassi des
comptes y compris palais ils répondent
tous à pied après vous regardez mais
dans une entreprise tiendrait pas parce
qu'une entreprise vous allez être jugé
sur ce que vous avez fait pas sur ce que
vous avez dit le monde politique vous
êtes juste que vous avez dit oui et là
et c'est pour ça que je me suis
renseigné par hercules et s'engage sur
tout mais mais effectivement j'ai osé ça
m'a pas fait que des amitiés de de toute
part je ne découvre un bon mois mais
quand j'ai déposé cette proposition lors
il y avait mis une maxime de de nstein
qui disait donc gagné par toulouse pour
besoin de moi pour ce premier n'a
einstein disait de points on ne peut pas
résoudre les problèmes avec les gens
qu'ils ont créé ça a mis de l'ambiance à
mes jeux il faut le dire le problème
c'est pas pour être un j'aime c'est pas
les gens que j'étais l'un est violent
mais cette école n'a plus de sens c'est
une des écoles les plus archaïques au
monde jure que trois obstacles parce
qu'il est brillant intellectuellement il
va pouvoir diriger un pays comme la
france en pleine mondialisation mais
elle avait du sang sans doute en 45
quand il fallait reconstruire les nuits
lana beaucoup moins aujourd'hui un mot
pour terminer sur la situation
économique de de saint quentin avec avec
cette crise sanitaire
évidemment ça pose des problèmes pour
les entreprises est ce que vous sentez
quand même que là il ya un regain est
que que les choses pourraient résoudre à
revenir dans l'ordre si je veux dire
dans les mois qui viennent à moi c'est
pour ça que à 50 ans mobilise avec tous
les maires pour pour que l'on puisse
redémarrer cette super belle machine
c'est une pépite saint quentin en
yvelines
certains d'entre eux patrick ses
finances et quand on voit il se dégrader
mais il faut remettre le plus vite
possible les gens qui sont volonté en
plus au travail pour reproduire de la
richesse pour garantir votre retraite
parce que 50% des recettes d'une
entreprise vont son redonner à l'état en
ce sens fiscal donc faut bien vous dire
que c'est urgent parce que sinon on déjà
votre retraite et pan dans un bel état
je rappelle enfin le texte
et voilà donc il faut il faut et puis la
santé si vous voulez si vous voulez
avoir un peu plus de folie
bien sûr de l'animation et bien regarder
pourquoi l'allemagne est meilleur que
nous sur les liaisons plus d'argent ce
donc il faut produire de la richesse
pour redistribuer pour et d'éducation
opérationnel et savent mieux faire
collaborer le public et le privé aussi
peut-être abandonné leur salle cette
espèce de guerre larvée entre le public
et le privé il faut arrêter ça mais ça
coûte ça coûte les 6 millions de
chômeurs ils sont là à dire le fait que
ces deux mondes se méprisent et se
comprennent pas c'est pour ça que je dis
faut 50% dans les cabinets et même les
six ans chef d'administration directeur
administration on veut 50% de gens qui
viennent de l'entreprise qui ont déjà
réformé quelque chose comment
voulez-vous réformer l'état si vous
laissez des gens qui n'ont jamais
réformé quoi que ce soit et quelque part
ils sont formés à g a géré la situation
en état mais ils n'ont pas cette culture
lors qu'il n'ya pas un chez un directeur
d'une entreprise qui a pas réformé amont
un service pas possible le monde a
tellement
donc il faut mélanger ses cultures c'est
une ferme mixité culturelle a pour un
peu au niveau de l'état et là
effectivement ce pays retrouvera une
position dans le monde qu'il n'aurait
jamais dû perdre
comment la communauté de saint quentin
évidemment il n' ya des aides de l'état
pour les entreprises comment vous aider
vous laisse des entreprises à passer ce
cap difficile tout en un service de
développement économique à saint quentin
avec des talents qui kills qui le dirige
aussi un mois et je peux vous dire on
est partout sur les petites entreprises
sur les commerces sur sur vaisseau libye
les grandes entreprises où et quand vous
voulez des renault le même le tour de
table c'est plus en milliards donc là il
à l'état de jouer il joue d'ailleurs
honnêtement nous bien pour les finances
autant je peux tu es salaam mais
honnêtement bien sûr ça augmente la
dette c'est vrai mais ça coûte moins
cher de soutenir que de lâcher et après
de reconstruire bon de toute façon donc
faut lever catastrophe sociale donc là
dessus le jeu fonctionne vraiment entre
l'état la région qui joue aussi un rôle
très important
et puis nous en développement mais ça
fonctionne mais je vous dis pas qu'on va
au combat tout résoudre
il ya un tiers des boîtes qui sort très
bien il ya un tiers des boîtes qui qui
qui souffrent mais qui vont passer entre
les gouttes mais qui souffre qui parle
de l'emploi etc et vous avez à faire des
routes qui sont vraiment en danger
donc voyez on est on est on doit gérer
ça ça va être un moment difficile vous
faut pas se cacher on est devant une
crise mondiale économique qui va quand
même à des conséquences ouais c'est vrai
que c'est exporter la politique
autrement
je trouve ça vous va bien non ben oui
mais moi je suis pour réconcilier le
monde économique
mais le monde économique et social je
suis docteur picaud du social vous dites
à l'heure mais je suis né à montreuil
mais bon je connais le social mais
social ça n'existe pas son économique
ayant économique il n'est pas nominé au
service de l'économie qui de service
social oui mais donc ça il faudrait
conflit il faut réconcilier ces deux ces
deux blocs avec l'état et l'état est au
service des français
tout individu qui l'oublieraient à mon
avis sera amené à à ce qu'ils aient une
vie de plus en plus difficiles quelque
chose soit claire et surtout peut nous
mettre dans une impasse donc voilà c'est
joueurs appellent ces c'est important le
peuple est souverain et même s'il a ses
excès de temps en temps ses maladresses
comme tout le monde politique aussi un
bon il faut réconcilier et qu'on attend
en français la réconciliation et surtout
que l'état sache se remettre à sa place
il en est sorti
il faut qu'il retrouve sa place merci
beaucoup
[Musique]